I mean noodle was coming she's like the
old stuff can come in your blog was full
and there were two loads of I mean
llama's bars then the glass you know
while the glasses are going this guy but
but I only remember then he's just he
was just a blackout Fang I just remember
getting it
and that's only the only two fault there
you have a [__] brother [__] my teeth
have been knocked out I've knocked out
um I couldn't tell you how long but by
the time I come around the fight was
still carrying on a car had been turned
over the window you know the pub was
blitzed
Man City at seven first game I went was
um he was City Tottenham and I wanted
one of the old rivals there to singing
to shouting and just do it togetherness
he was just like a surge that someone
come through like I'd rather she was
like whoa in all the years
yeah it was just straight away it was
just hooked hooked on the football so I
think he gets sucked into it didn't you
definitely and uh I think like similar
sort of working class background and now
she's like talking tubes like it's
something like yourself especially
that background you have when you come
from like the East End and like like
where you where you've grew up as well
I grew up in in half Manchester me to
believe that which is like the United
side of town you know main road is so
did you say exactly yeah and someone was
like they want a lot of Blue Blues where
I agree so as soon as I I know and I
felt like I didn't really fit in
anywhere so as soon as I've been to him
Lord I was like
um I want that you know yeah that's for
me yeah yeah the biggest game ever I
think it's like 67 um uh West Western
playing man united yeah no season 67 and
George best was playing Dennis Law if
you bump you know Bobby Charlton all of
them and then that's when I really sort
of like I looked around and I see like
the quick you know the crowd like they
were about 20 000 man united but they
serve a lot of London Reds
I remember the whole win got thousands
of man united fans there and that's when
I first sort of felt that position I
like looking around like youngster
growing up when you just the surgeon
everything else and then obviously
getting a bit older by the time I was
like 13 14 just just winning the fight
yeah because just looking at the old a
lot you know what I mean I mean I
remember like going to some of the
derbys in man united their name I was
[__] excited I couldn't eat I felt
sick you know all the excitement and
yeah that was it just took over your
life yeah and then like like first time
going nothing I was like Arsenal away
something like that and we were all like
kids you know I mean I've been throwing
forward but we fought you know bowling
down the road and he's like we've gone
there they would say I'd be not Library
the North Bank and I'm saying we'd come
around the corner and there was these
main there because like that four or
five years difference yeah I'm looking
for
Manchester Derby where United got in in
this in the city end in a knife stand
did Chad sit in after it was good enough
and it was just like me watching that it
was like
so obviously you know there's only one
way I was going to go when when it
started kicking off it becomes a
recession didn't it it wasn't Obsession
yeah
I think so say football violence is a
drug but it is is it within your own
Circle it's they stop people going out
just to beat people up yeah someone will
pass yeah they're going to give you
someone to dig because he's got an adult
show they say it's
I suppose it's just like sort of
you're feeding your own chart like
adrenaline or shot you yeah you know and
I mean we did go to support the club for
the same you know yeah
you know it's that you know but just
being like with a Ladson and you're
there you're there for real ads you know
whatever like you know if you say West
I'm coming to Manchester I was coming
down there you know that's your that's
your patch yeah yeah you've got to be
out and you've got a room you can
connect it you feel like you felt like
you're fighting on behalf of your team
yeah
it's just it's it's it's the battle
wouldn't it yeah it is and that was a
big thing we needed to oh it's just I
can't describe it unless you've actually
experienced it and been part of it and
been involved in it you you then you can
only really understand it I think it's
it's like a mix of emotions because you
don't know what's going to happen and
you know it can come on top you can get
it you know there's that many people
involved yeah and it's always like
because you know we all get a bit lucky
it's on top here you know and you're
going for it and it's just a buzzing you
know you don't know and you've got to
stand your [__] ground you can think
you know dmh easy meat especially
and uh I see you come around the corner
who's been saying we're all fighting and
straight just running across and then
we'll do the old Bill come past with the
old season they come by some better
yellow and then yeah and drag you down
the road and all that but you it was
like back to the wall do you love me
yeah and sometimes that's the best Buzz
yeah I suppose like you when you think
you know you manage to get away or
whatever it's like it's like a little
victory in it yeah yeah well I think
work class people like it's part of life
to fight ain't it yeah yeah to survive
you're like whether you're at school
some of those digs you out or you know
something happens or as you're growing
up you're out and someone calls it on
it's a fall out of it yeah but I just
think it's a different level
of course yeah definitely yeah yeah and
the ones who aren't like they're never
rare yeah but they're not Fighters if
you know what I mean I've always seen
anything
that they need to see that yeah yeah
I've always said that if you go over the
firm and see if he's like in my movie's
gone it might have only been 50 but if
it's the 10 at the front yeah
yeah they're they're gonna follow you
know if if one if you start black enough
you know sometimes it's just just a lot
like this you know there's more there
yeah but most of the time he was the
first time out of here yeah that do the
business
you'd look at that
you see things in football like like 200
degrees is running 200 gazes then we
didn't want to be 200 gazes fighting 200
gazers no no no if this is the first
time yeah it'd be the fighters yeah
fighting the fighters you know what I
mean one word it was bad it was um it
was a Manchester Derby played United
um
not long after we moved here
so we want we want like the team what we
are now we want nearly winning much I
think we've probably started like
mid-table fighting probably fighting
relegation at the time United was going
for the you know for the league and we
just we knew it was going to go after oh
we did on a derby day we was out he was
fighting out outside the ground all the
way down to town like and it just
chilled out for an hour or two everyone
was having a pain we all got the phone
call to go to this Boozer
um and we knew he was coming slightly
almost [__] coming it was about 50 60
Us in abujah end of the season nice and
warm King everyone's got a t-shirts only
in the Beer Garden
um and then the the shower went up like
today so we come under this bridge and
like they said when the road's full
your boat is full and there is a I mean
llama's bars all sorts of something like
like he was just like you know you stuck
her back nearly run into each other and
then the glass you know while the
glasses are going this guy but
um but I only remember then he's just he
was just a blackout Fang I just remember
getting it and I know I got it and
that's how many teeth out there you have
a [__] brother [__] my teeth have
been knocked out I've knocked out
um I couldn't tell you how long but by
the time I come down the fight we're
still carrying on a car had been turned
over the window you know the pub was
blitzed and that's probably the worst
the worst fantasy and it went on for 15
minutes
anyway anyway we've got to Alban we used
to do the changing line and then we went
to go to Houston
and there was a normal crowd it was like
oh I've got about 50 of us and we just
had a little click I don't know why I
was all staying on the platform and and
the central line that it could come in I
know it's in the film and then the doors
open but we see mural yeah oh boys over
there you're [__] doing
but the whole [__] train was movable
it was there well there were the whole
firm and it was like 50 of us so but
we've gone in the middle carries like
we're like we've all got in one case
fighting and they need to just went like
Windows [__] things and they were
like there was these box things they
were pulling bits of wood air blades and
it it just seemed like forever do you
know I mean everyone was on the floor
like the whole Carriage because about as
long as this yeah I think that and he
was just they were coming and coming and
come just through the windows the
windows went through they would smashed
it with them with all the stuff the
glass everywhere and I'll just
it's just like fighting from your life
you know because I knew if I went down I
was sort of seeing since someone went
down it was like 567 meal we'll smashing
so I don't know how I had a young one
with me but I'm amazing not like the
guys are like I've got onto the platform
like that and then I've chopped up like
double taped and then they're all
that I could just see everyone laying on
the deck you know I mean I thought it's
cool I've got to go yeah I thought
actually full so after a great kid I
went come on you we've thrown up that
the platform but they've chased us now
because old one you've got goes off all
over the place there [__] similar was
running about oh that happened they kept
trying to get us and all that and then
we've got up to another one the other
levels and we just jumped on the train
so I just thought it was about 30 and 40
in this year 15 this young young and all
that
[Laughter]
like I said yeah
I think I've been next about probably
about 10 times out of football
um but I did get nicked got Nicks for
him a violent disorder I was looking I
thought I'm gonna get jail here he said
to me looking at five years a lot of our
young Lads have started to come through
then
um and back we played Barnsley and cup
they brought a load down they've been on
the phone so a lot of young ladder was
phoning me said you know they're coming
down and coming down I'm like no no I
don't know don't know okay you know what
let's go out
it's about 40 of them in there for like
50 of them in there we've gone in had a
bit of a chance I'd like no come on you
know we're having it like he said so
anyway one thing's been he said turnover
next thing is the Pub's gone up tables
chairs Parts a lot I have had something
smashed in my eyes on my eyes okay it's
been smashed in and they've ended up
getting off police have been found glass
everywhere
and and then the next thing we've added
to the ground I think Vans have come
been spotted on CCTV and landed up but
I'll lifted and I thought you know what
he's can't do it you can't do it these
days cameras everywhere there's about 30
of us in the dock
um even if the ladder from Panzer that
we're fighting with Dave's in the dark
river so he was having a bit of a bit of
abandon in the doctor like they'd come
down and like that's a split or so many
I think it's about 30 of us all together
so it was in a docking like I'm actually
like last night
fancy long too in a bit like
I'm doing a bit he [__] Matthew
what I mean
um luckily enough that that case
collapsed so I got away with that one
but then pretty much straight after I
got on him got another Banning order
five year Banning I did again yeah and
actually exactly I thought you know what
I'm thinking this level 30 was trying to
do the stent down on the football
violence which is early 80s yeah yeah
yeah yeah
it's just like there's obviously the
segregations fences were going up and
then all the undercover stuff come in to
try and take your tax out and all that
did you have any like oh I stand like
another undercover application yeah yeah
yeah yeah sum them up tips me off right
about my name is seen in the PlayStation
so I went down to five and I was just
said to him I went listen I've said I've
had a little chipmunks they didn't
season I went they was they was already
going with West Ham they didn't know you
there was a little firm like blokes was
started yeah I don't know how Bowser I'm
going away games no one knew they were
people didn't even drink in there anyway
unless you knew each other I did it it
was one of them once and uh and I just
like got this thing I was just sit on
they're honest they want us like that
I've got yeah I've just done 10 years
home and away I'm gonna miss about four
games I mean religion yeah home and away
every time for 10 years sorry that was
from 17 to I was about 27. and I thought
you know I'll just try to tell him I
thought I've got Missy's kids and all
that and the fines now people were doing
birds and I was in a bit door work as
well and I so I'm just thinking like
trying to earn a few quid now
and then I thought and as I said to him
well I went this in I said dishonest
like that I said I've had a little
little thing and uh I can't say on
camera I've got it but I did and I've
done it but no one's heavy yeah and then
next thing I know they we um we had this
ass like load of us we'll split up
everything's now we used to take birds
around and all that and out of these
rooms and all of a sudden they [__]
found out where he was there huh but I
weren't there I might I would make the
shoes in my room with these birds and
can they put the doors through and
everything they even knew that they was
following us everything and and I would
just went on a little disappearing at
Miss and they couldn't find me but they
yeah then it's about
I remember about 20 of us all the main
ones
the things was happening in my life
really away from football sort of like
you know did the drinking drug culture
sort of
suck a grip on me and it I was trying to
like it I found myself in a bit of a bad
way you know what I mean but a drinking
a dog sort of like I've got an addictive
personality so if I like something
the car get enough of it whether that's
football violence you know women
drinking drugs
it's like more more so and that's how it
was for me so in the end he was like I
wasn't even in a position to go fighting
out the football you know what I mean I
was um I was just
I was I was like well well off the mark
do you know what I mean
I think pretty similar I think like
we will put the wishes through and
everything like suburbing the mortgage
naming kids and staffers and all that we
we took vehement and we went to
Sunderland but we left on the like
Friday like late night Friday night but
like and I've been for Van like you know
we don't look at the band yeah like 20
of us because he felt like get out there
we go for a few mattresses in back here
a few beers and all that in them guys so
we drove out and get there early in the
morning do the little surprise ones you
know I mean jump out the back of the van
but what we did I think on the way back
I think it was a Donny with Doncaster
yeah we've we thought that we stopped my
phone have a few beers Saturday night on
the way back but man united have been in
there and played or something there's a
lot of man united fans there as well
done the Doncaster yeah
so we're in the Boozer
there's about 20 of us in the van so
we're standing there just like got one
of the boozers I think we need to cut a
little bit bits of paint now like you
know like like through the northern
beats you know about a few beers
standing there all of a sudden the
window went through
for that you know doors can everything
is coming through
mainly night I've done all the locals
they're all exercises like we say that
for two or three hundred [__] people
there's 20 of us in the Boozer so
landlords can get them trying to push
this out the doors but they're trying to
come in at the doors but the 20 of us
were like mostly whereas who lights
around but in the end it was I think it
was we just kept split up because you
didn't pull the dragged away I didn't
know you didn't even know where to go
and I remember the last three of us it
was me my Vinnie and the one of us but
where's [__] running back to the van
in the van we ain't got who's got the
keys to the [__] van all right
so got to the van but it was just the
old slide that one you know just slide
up [__] roller Fisher thing
I went twice
they were like looking for us you know
what I mean so so we slid up I mean jump
in the back the pump shot there so he
pulled it down
a little bit so the favorite stands on
it and we could even
shaking event
they're in the veins
we're standing on the three of us on
this lip to stop the roller coming up
thing like that and they're all around
the van like that there is something
there's three of them they must be over
there so I'm gonna deliver another Raw
it's kicking off I thought it's the rest
of us I mean
like The Avengers
fighting again and everybody like we're
all fighting now like so everyone they
did back to the van like I don't know it
might be about 50 of them now next we
know and they put the windows through
and they smashed on the front window the
side bits so we're gonna get down the
road to a service on the motorway get on
the first service station get some
plastic and just tape it up right so we
left Friday night on Sunday this is the
days before mobile phones so I've just
walked in stunk same clothes on
[Laughter]
um
and had a phone call to go out to the
game and you know I took him to a
relative so I'd be back in a couple of
hours and I didn't end up coming back I
ended up getting filled in lifted and he
was there till the next day you know
when I come in and I was battered and
everything and seen him the next day you
know he was upset you know crying that
lives matter he don't remember that now
but boy lives I mean watching him there
thinking that's the point that was one
little regret I think it is
because you're younger when you're going
early 20s now but as you get older you
did like you you know kids are thinking
about the same day you know and then
it's like my boy and if I take him
one I won once I wouldn't want to see
him fight no no no no you mean certainly
changes but it doesn't mean that you
don't want to be that person
or you've got a new grits for it because
the end of the day like
I loved every moment of it and if I
could
the 60 words if I could ever go back and
have that my favorite span of my life it
would always be even my 10 years on The
Terraces fighting and doing what I did
because I loved every moment of it I
love the passion the adrenaline and it
was the most addictive thing I've ever
done in my life see I can't really say
you know I regret what I've done because
I just believe that that was my path you
know yeah I've learned by my mistakes
you know but if I didn't make their
mistakes it won't be the man who I am
now yeah and that that that's that's I
think that's that's part of life with no
matter what path you go down it's it's
what it's what makes you it's it's what
you are
you know
I think it's like a generation thing
like might be we've had 10 years of it
yeah I mean like they might in your your
age some of them they're in your 10
years and I think you you can't keep you
can't carry on like that for 20 30 years
no no you can't and like you said when
you get to that certain point where
you've done 10 years and you're one of
the top buyers and the old building all
your
you've achieved what you wanted to
achieve and I think like
being with like your firm your people
that's your adopted family and having a
great time and be in touch with the tree
yeah that's it yeah memories yeah the
times and the way life now at football
is completely different it's a whole
different culture the way it's run the
way it ways places I think
we had the the start of it you at the
end of it and the best years but yeah
and
and those people are going to judge us I
think you're used to you you cut your
cut off just enough and whatever you
think you are but
you you can't
describe it you had to be part of it to
understand it and no one will ever no no
don't matter what you would say to any
audience where two million people sit
and watches and go wow they get like
three quarters a month ago I don't get
that what do they want about what what
but honestly it's a it's a it's a thing
it's part of life
it's just as a man it made me the main
momentarily you know what I mean
there was a guy sitting on the train
opposite with his wife and his two kids
and he had a Crystal Palace lapel badge
just a little badge on his jacket
the guy saw it he lent the cross and he
punched the bloke squarely in the face
and then hit him three more times in
front of his wife and his two kids